Brian Kirsten Tropicana dilemmas
continue that diverging diamond up in
over I-15 is closing the Tropicana
Bridge from Midnight until tomorrow
morning Ryan Matheny joins us live near
the bridge now with why Enda says to
expect even more closures ahead Ryan
got Brian this is what hundreds of
people on The Strip are trying to get to
I can taste why and not even they
confirm this is the busiest in and out
in the state and not only is the
diverging diamond making it confusing to
get there but so are the temporary
materials being used during this
long-term project
foreign
we saw it months ago
and we're still seeing it now drivers
incorrectly navigating tropicana's
diverging diamond a road interchange
meant to improve traffic flow which
temporarily directs drivers to the
opposite side of the road I said I'm
lost where's the in and out it's the one
obstacle on the most convenient route
from the strip to this burger chain
Ronaldo purposefully avoids it in fact I
told him don't go that way because we're
going to have a hassle which I did
as Crews worked to widen and raise the
Tropicana bridge that is no longer tall
enough to meet Federal requirements and
it was busy it was packed people are
seemingly coming here less than before
according to the store security they're
complaining that it's more difficult to
get over here they don't like taking the
back roads to get here this will be our
fourth closure overnight expect more
closures here public information officer
Justin Hopkins says the rain and
constant driving is fading striping in
retro-reflective markers on the road all
of this that has been put down is
temporary during construction so as such
comes up it fades with time it needs to
be refreshed this overnight closure
meant to address that and to address
drivers like these it can be a little
bit confusing if you add too many signs
so we're trying to find the happy medium
of how much signage should be there and
and what is the most effective way to
put it all in there
adds a more frequent problem they're
seeing is right here on your screen some
drivers getting off the freeway towards
this in and out will make the far left
turn to get on there though the
diverging diamond it does require
drivers to make that immediate left turn
and Dot adds they are engineering new
ways to address that as well reporting
live over I-15 at Tropicana with my
lunch Ryan Matthey eight news now
Kirsten has asked for a double double
Ryan if we could she'll be eating it in
the car of course these overnight main
enclosures there's the diverging diamond
will take place every couple months or
so according to ndot a diverging diamond
will remain in place on this bridge
right through 2024.